hello and welcome to Tech deals in the
1990s we had dozens dozens of different
companies making graphic ships for the
PC today we have two companies AMD and
Nvidia and that's kind of sad when you
think about the rapid iteration we used
to enjoy it back then
thankfully a third player has entered
the battle Intel has finally launched
the long-awaited arc a770 dedicated GPU
bringing a third option into the
discrete graphics card Market
oh do I have a lot to say about this one
please sit back and relax grab a drink
grab a snack and let's get into it
[Music]
today's video was brought to you by ewin
racing the best source for gaming chairs
in desk for those long gaming sessions
we have a playlist of our Ewing chair
and desk videos Linked In the video
description below save 30 off of
everything using the discount code Tech
deals more details at the end of the
video
Intel's new arc a770 is not like they're
traditionally terrible integrated
Graphics of yesterday this is a serious
GPU for serious Gamers Gamers and
content creators one day but that day
isn't today for now it's just gaming
what would you say to 349 dollars for a
graphics card that can handle 1440p
Ultra wide at high detail that can hold
60 frames per second in the one percent
low and comes with 16 gigabytes of vram
you would probably say that's a deal or
you should because it is sort of we'll
get to the sort of in just a minute the
closest competition is the RX 6700 XT
from AMD that card has 12 gigabytes of
vram which is enough for a hot minute
but it's really not faster than the
Intel card and it does tend to cost a
little bit more nvidia's option is the
RX 3070 it has a woeful 8GB gigabytes of
vram which is not enough for 1440p Ultra
wide gaming today and it won't be enough
for any 1440p gaming in a hot minute or
two it also costs more than the arc a770
so easy win from Intel everyone should
Rush right out now and buy one not so
fast there are some asterisks here that
need to be talked about before we get to
those allow me to show you some game
footage this is Ghost Recon breakpoint
running at 1440p Ultra wide at high
detail for those of you who don't know
1440p Ultra wide is 50 percent more
pixels on screen versus standard 1440p
it's 5 million versus 3.6 so it's quite
demanding to run the arc a770 is
averaging around 75 frames per second
and it's holding a one percent low of
60. this means that 99 of the time your
frame rates are above 60 frames per
second which is a solid result from a
350 dollar graphics card in a demanding
open world game like breakpoint I
honestly played breakpoint longer than I
needed to for The Benchmark it was
smooth and playable in all respects no
complaints for 350 it is a solid value
for this game at this resolution so
what's not to like don't worry we'll get
there next we have the division two
another one of my favorite games from
2018 all also running at 1440p Ultra
wide also running at high detail this
time the performance isn't quite as good
we averaged 60 frames per second and
held a 48 one percent low which is still
perfectly fine at least for the single
player stuff I wouldn't want to get into
the dark Zone at this level of
performance multiplayer will drop off
and you will either need to compromise
detail settings or resolution or you
need more graphics card
speaking of more GPU this is a good time
to point out something that gets
overlooked all too often you can pick
from good fast and cheap but you can
only pick two of them at a time if you
have a performance problem typically the
application of money will fix it if you
want a large boost in performance the
liberal application of money will fix it
here is the division two again at 1440p
Ultra wide however this time we are at
Ultra detail this is playing on my
personal gaming computer at home
featuring an I9 9900k and the
performance is notably faster we are at
100 frames per second and that's
honestly not even as fast as it will go
because I've got vsync turned on at home
but wait it gets better my home PC is
not being recorded by an external
machine as the Arc a77 was in the
previous recording this is OBS recording
using nvenc on my 3090 to capture this
footage at 100 megabits per second in
high quality mode plus I have a slower
CPU at home to boot let's review 66
percent higher frame rate higher detail
setting GPU being used to record the
footage and a slower CPU right now used
RTX 3090 cards are selling for under 750
dollars on eBay just over double the
cost of a new arc a770. it's an option
to consider if you're looking to make
your performance problems go away now
that we've covered the good let's talk
about the bad the arc a77 is awesome if
you're playing a DirectX 12 or Vulcan
game as we just were it's how do I put
this less so if you're playing a DirectX
11 game this is Grand Theft Auto 5
everybody's favorite 2013 console
release launched in 2015 for the PC and
it plays very well at 1440p Ultra wide
at very high detail it almost holds 60
frames per second not quite but it's
quite playable if you want to get 60
frames per second you will have to lower
the detail settings to high detail we
averaged 49 frames per second with a 34
in the one percent low which is playable
but now that I actually think about it
is terrible considering this is a
seven-year-old PC game and a
nine-year-old console game yes really
The Arc a770 should be embarrassed by
these numbers now In fairness some
DirectX 11 games run better than others
it depends upon how much recent
development the game has received how
much driver development work Intel has
done and perhaps a visit from Lady Luck
I had planned to run this card through
our entire GPU test Suite of 17 games
however one game stopped me dead in my
tracks Assassin's Creed Syndicate is
probably not a name you've heard of in a
long time
here you're watching a GTX 1080 on an fx
8300 at 1440p very high detail having no
issues holding 60 frames per second
yes that's right FX from AMD is running
Assassin's Creed just fine
Syndicate came out in 2015. it's seven
years old so yeah an fx and a GTX 1080
will run this without complaint how
about something not quite so trash Panda
the ryzen 7 1700x and a GTX 1080 TI
again 1440p and we have 99 frames per
second average and a 77 one percent low
Stellar performance no issues whatsoever
which is exactly what you'd expect from
a 2015 game you can buy a GTX 1080 TI
used off of eBay for just over 200 with
11 gigabytes of vram it's solid for
1080P and 1440p gaming even in 2022 if
you're not trying to play the absolutely
newest games
so clearly an I9 10900k and an Intel arc
a770 graphics card released in 2022 with
16 gigabytes of vram and Modern
Performance should have no issues right
right before I show you that result here
is Assassin's Creed Syndicate running on
my home PC being captured on the RTX
3090 via OBS and nvenc this is 1440p
ultra wide with ultra detail selected
again this is not a clean test bench
however I did this after a fresh reboot
and nothing else was running other than
the game Steam ubisoft's launcher MSI
afterburner and OBS recording footage no
issues with performance other than some
slowdown due to the recording and Ultra
wide at Ultra detail 71 frames per
second average and 53 in the one percent
low perfectly playable and lovely
overall it was quite demanding on both
the CPU and the GPU which just goes to
show you that even older games can ask a
lot if you crank it all to the max now
let's take a look at Syndicate on the
Intel Arc a770 1440p Ultra wide High
detail and wait a minute this can't be
right eight frames per second and an
ultra wide aspect ratio was broken
clearly something is wrong now I did
mess around with that it was set to 21.9
I did double check it just refused to
properly adjust to it worked fine on the
other games on this card and of course
it also worked fine on my machine at
home okay forget Ultra wide let's go to
standard 1440p normal 16 9 aspect ratio
High detail and that'll fix it uh
Houston we have a problem 10 frames per
second is not fixed what the heck is
going on here this is only controllable
because I'm not really doing anything
I'm just running around the map you
could not play the game like this how
about low detail that'll fix it right
well I did manage to average 14 frames
per second at 1440p low detail so
victory
I'm joking of course this is completely
non-playable in every sense of the word
this right here is where I stopped my
testing and I reconsidered how I was
going to cover this card because that
was unacceptable a 350 dollar graphics
card in 2022 that cannot play a 2015
game at all is simply not an acceptable
result I did test a few other games
performance was all over the place
sometimes it was fine sometimes it was
not I ultimately decided against doing
our full GPU test Suite as it takes
about 10 hours to take a single card
through it and I decided this card
wasn't worth the 10 hours of testing
time it is rare indeed that I give a not
recommended rating to anything that I
make a video on but in this case I have
to say this card is not recommended for
purchase when it's fine it's fine it
performs well against modern cards in
modern games using DirectX 12 and Vulcan
but in in older games it is all over the
place ranging from worse than a
five-year-old GPU to unplayable it would
be easy to say well who cares about one
old game I want to play new games and
that's fine you can spend your money
however you want however a 350 RX 6700xt
will play Modern games about as well as
the a770 and it'll also play all the old
games on top of that the only two things
that you really get out of the a770 are
16 gigabytes of vram and av1 Hardware
encoding which I haven't talked about up
to this point first to address the 16
gigabytes of vram it is pretty cool
however the a770 lacks the compute
performance to make effective use of it
so it's more of a feel-good measure
eight gigabytes on the RTX 3070 is not
enough but the 12 gigabytes on the RX
6700xt really is second the av1 encode
aspect is nice and there is absolutely a
place for it however I couldn't get it
to work in OBS using either av1 profile
however that may very well be addressed
in a patch soon enough it is a brand new
card after all I had planned to spend
more time talking about some of the
unique features of the Intel Arc gpus
however that plan ended once I saw the
DirectX 11 performance and syndicate's
performance specifically
allow me to leave you on this thought
imagine that you buy a shiny new 350
a770 and it plays your modern games just
fine you're happy overall right up until
you pick up some older games on a steam
sale that you missed playing a few years
ago you're excited to load them up and
play it Ultra detail because hey seven
year old game should be easy as pie
right then you load up the game and you
discover not only can you not play at
Ultra you can't even play it high you
can't even play it low it's simply
non-functional your old graphics card
would do it but your new one will not
I don't know about you but I'd be upset
about that thus the Intel Arc a770 is
not recommended due to its unreliable
DirectX 11 performance hopefully Intel
can work on the drivers and address this
in future updates I would love to
revisit this in the future and find that
it's been fixed e-win racing has a wide
selection of chairs to fit all shapes
and sizes of Gamers ranging from petite
to cuddly they have something for every
type of gamer not just sizes but colors
and material options as well including
red blue purple pink orange and more
plus cloth and leather choices we have
over half a dozen chair and desk videos
in a playlist down in the video
description below we also have a very
special offer just for Tech deals
viewers save 30 off of everything using
discount code Tech deals using our Link
in the video description we have used
e-win gaming chairs for three years in
our office sitting on them for up to
eight hour Marathon live streams they
are very comfortable and we are happy to
work with ewin to bring you this special
discount and recommend ewin for all of
your gaming chair and desk needs
thank you all so much for watching to
the very end of this video two gold
stars for all of you still here like
comment subscribe and do all of the
things links in the video description
below including to some of the used
graphics card options seriously folks
use GTX 1070 1080 and 1080 TI cards are
really getting down there in price on
eBay and even some 20 series cards are
starting to fall in price if you want a
new card the RX 6700 XT is basically
this with better DirectX 11 performance
and enough vram to be fine I will of
course link this down there below for
some of you who just absolutely insist
to be contrarians and go do your own
thing and you do you but really DirectX
11 is all over the place I hope they fix
it and drivers I really do I want a
third competitor in the GPU space that
would be pretty awesome let me know what
you think in the comment section below
appreciate you watching I will see all
of you next time
speaking of more GPU this is a good time
to point out something that gets
overlooked all too often you can put
you can put you can put it you can put
it you can put it in your computer
see that's the problem with winging it
and adding words is I put the word
liberal in the second sentence and it
wasn't in the first but I added it to
the first because I wanted to put it in
the first and then it sounds dumb when
it's in the second
I'd advise lowering the high detail to
raise the average closer to 60 but we
got 49 who wrote these words okay
yes really The Arc a7070 should be A7
7770 the arc
Intel
your product name is stupid
um we were at 70 usage on a 2015 game on
my 9900k
you remember when I was rebooting my
machine so it was a clean reboot by the
way we were using 20 gigs of main system
RAM and 10 gigs of vram
now that was Ultra turn it to high and
those numbers come way down
liberal application of money I need a
coffee mug that says liberal application
of money
make all this go away 30 90 bro 30 90.
[Music]